yeah I think um know your market so
whether that's Tech Finance whatever it
might be just like have a good
understanding of you know who are the
big players you know if it's the
technology stack the tech Stack's
actually trying to understand them so
you know when you're able to have client
calls and candidate calls you'll be
you're able to understand them too and
kind of knowing about so like I
specifically done Munich for instance so
that was my Niche so knowing that market
in general
um as I said knowing the big players
where the funding comes from
um who are the you know key key
companies who are the small companies
who are the big companies and yeah just
like knowing that community of like
you're kind of community and your client
community and you're only going to know
that through experience and you know
speaking with more and more people so
knowing that market in general although
it sounds very vague but not again I'm
just really commit to being an expert in
understanding the nuances what's going
on yeah yeah so in a nutshell Niche now
um Niche now so that you know you're
you're an expert in in one specific area
or technology or industry whatever it
might be I would say again play the long
game
um you know when I started out
um doing doing perm I was just looking
for short wins you know because at that
time we just had to you know keep the
lights on and make sure we're we're
making uh we're making money so I didn't
think long term
um so like actually thinking long term
and building relationships and you know
someone is not looking now asking them
what would you be looking for when you
are looking so that you've already got a
good amount of knowledge and you know
already what they will be looking for so
that you know if someone does come up
you know you can still send them to them
and you've built some sort of foundation
so playing the long long game and
building relationships and making sure
you're staying in touch with these
people so like you know dropping them a
LinkedIn connection dropping them an
email with a little bit about what you
guys do although they're not looking
right now speaking of them in a few
weeks or a few months and then just
keeping keeping in touch also I would
say add value
like whatever you do try to add value
whether you're speaking to a candidate
or a client and it doesn't have to be in
your interest you know they don't have
to be hiring or looking for a job you
know if you see something on the CV that
you can you know give them some advice
on do that if you can give them some
insight on the market do that if you can
tell them like give them some tips on
hiring do that so like add value in in
whatever you do and whoever you speak to
just aim to leave that call with adding
value because that's how they'll
Remember You The recruitment podcast is
proudly sponsored by VIN cherry and the
award-winning Source breaker